how many art classes have you taken as
an adult whether it's music filmmaking
I have taken no art classes since high
school unfortunately
um maybe I should now that you say that
I'm like oh man should I go take some
more classes
um none I took like guitar lessons from
like a local guy for five dollars a
lesson in high school I was in AV club
in high school so I shot like all the
football games all the plays all that
stuff on VHS
um I did Ceramics back then I did
painting back then
um but yeah no as an adult I've just
been like I'm going to do this I think
like in the 90s when all the riot girl
stuff was going on I just had it in my
head if I could just make it to a city
I'll get in a band and I'll make it
again that will be like you know my
lottery ticket you know out of like
Rural America
um and I think that was kind of like the
dream that was fed to us like in the 90s
like in magazines and everything like
you know you're just in a band you'll do
great so I have that in my head like if
I just get to a city album it's all fine
and so that's exactly what I did I like
moved from rural New York to Boston and
I was like I'm in a city now it's going
to be great I didn't quite realize like
nobody cares about anything that's
happening in Boston like I wish I knew
like earlier I needed to go to New York
or La
um not that it might have made any
difference at all you know because now I
have this great body of work I was able
to do there
um
but yeah I just dove in I started going
to open mics I met my partner doing
music we started a lot of bands we did
bands for 10 years we toured the country
we released a lot of Records
um
so yeah that was kind of like like going
back to what we were saying before like
I just dive in it doesn't matter that I
don't know how to play bass or I don't
know how to play drums I'm like I'll
learn it on the spot that's always what
I've done you know like I have a sense
of what it's supposed to be like and
like we'll just make it happen
did they have pay to play back then
because I know that was part of the
Sunset Strip and that was a criticism
yeah it wasn't so bad in Boston that I
had like a little bit there was like
some you know these bands with or bills
with like 20 bands on them and like you
had to sell X number of tickets to like
play the gig
um but yeah mostly I was able to stay
away from that stuff and like certainly
with like College radio and stuff there
was like a lot of Paola at that time
like you know from like record companies
but I was never really associated with
the record company that was gonna like
put up some money to like get my song to
number one you know
um but I always feel like I was in the
wrong decade you know like I I because I
was doing very like Angry Girl music and
like by the time I was doing that it was
more like the indie rock guy kind of
music so like I feel like you know had I
been a little older in like the early
90s or the 70s it might have you know
worked a little bit better I always feel
a little bit with film too like I kind
of miss like the moment where like
people were making money on indie films
like either like the mid 90s or the
early 2000s if you were able to make a
film like on 16 mil or something I feel
like it got out you know
um but you know maybe the moment's still
to come
sure well so this was though after the
hairband revolution so then grunge had
started is that for where I think I
would land yeah like the early 90s I
sure would have been so good because I
mean there was that shift here in La
where you know you would see these guys
and girls promoting their bands on you
know with their flyers and stuff up and
down the Sunset Strip and it was insane
and then once Nirvana and you know
Allison changed it just totally changed
the whole you know Taste Of Music so oh
yeah
um but do you feel like you you if
because there were some angry you know
that I mean it wasn't like weird like
Susie and the Banshees kind of cool you
know British stuff but it was still
there was you know yeah like if I could
have been like in L7 in LA in the 90s I
would have been a happy camper
sure how many instruments can you play
um I play
kind of badly like guitar Basin drums so
like the standard Rock Trio I can do all
that yeah and how did you teach yourself
um So guitar when I was younger I did
take lessons like but like you know not
too too seriously I was mostly like I
need to know five chords so I can write
my song you know and I was really into
Bob Dylan Like as like a young kid in
addition to like grunge and Courtney
Love and all that stuff but I like loved
like folk music I think from my parents
were like old hippies so it's just like
around you know and so you know his
voice is terrible like I love it but
like I was like I don't need to sing
that great like whatever the words are
what matters you know and so it's always
like how can I get enough
of a chord structure and a Melody just
to get my words out
um so that's why I started on guitar it
was just the easiest and then later
um once I was doing bands and stuff it
was really hard to keep a drummer
um I think that's true for every rock
band like the drummers just come and go
and I was getting so frustrated and I
had a friend over and I was like he lent
me a drum kit and I put it in my
basement and he gave me like a couple
lessons and then I was off so I you know
my old band did not forsake me my
darling I play drums my partner played
bass and that was it I didn't need
anybody else we played for a long time
like that just the two of us but I have
white stripes yeah I guess people were
always comparing us to even though it
really sound like that
um but again it was just like taking
that power back because I'm like I can't
depend on some dude who's on drugs to
like come and play this gig for me you
know that had so many bad experiences I
fired a guy on stage once because he was
so messed up he couldn't play and I was
like I'll just play the show myself like
go
um so like after having enough of those
I was like the drums were holding me
back so that's what I'm gonna learn uh
you know and I like
very much into punk rock you know so
it's like I only need to know so much
you know I was like I was fine it was a
straight ahead drummer you know but it's
nothing fancy like I didn't need to do a
ton of fills it was like enough that I
could just sing on top of
um and then with my friends and stuff
you know they need a bass player I'm
like I can do that because like I had
enough guitar and I had enough knowing
now Rhythm from drums I was like faces
with a nice little middle ground uh
Bridge those two instruments so I played
bass with some friends for a while
um which I do I like I like bass a lot
more than guitar uh it's just like it
sounds better to me I just like the
tones better
um but yeah is there a comparable uh
drummer on set to the film person on set
as who's gonna mess you up them up maybe
sound
like who's gonna not show up and it
really messes you up like you can't
continue okay okay oh yeah someone told
me that they were at a Who concert and
Keith Moon passed out and they had to
like scan the audience for a drama that
knew the song and someone did they knew
yeah they brought them up but I mean I I
don't I didn't know that about bands I
don't know that much about music culture
that I would know that drummers weren't
always reliable I don't know why they're
very unreliable but it was always like
uh in Boston if there was a good drummer
they were in 20 bands already so then
you're scheduling around the drummer you
know because like he's like well I've
got practice with this guy Monday
Wednesday Friday I was like a nightmare
to keep one on board
um so I just I was like no I'm just
gonna go do it and like that's been my
ethos because I think because I come
from kind of like a punk rock mentality
like DIY was so big it like impressioned
on me as a child like just do it
yourself
um that I never thought like I couldn't
I was like give me a month and I'll be
good enough
sure how did you learn cinematography
same so
um like you know we
I did some AV club in high school that's
not cinematography though that's just
like with the camera on the play you
know um so I had an interest and I had
an interest in photography
um I'm a terrible photographer still to
this day I'm actually like trying to get
back into it because it's just like a
little different and people always hand
me a camera and they're like take a
photo I'm like no if you're not moving I
can't do it
um but it was just kind of bored out of
necessity so you know we were in bands
we wanted to make music videos we did a
couple with directors that ended up
being very expensive you know like
paying for their cruise and even if the
directors did it for free just the the
whole production was expensive and we're
like we can't afford to do like us you
know music video for like every song on
our record if we don't do it ourselves
so we bought like a crappy little
Panasonic like zoom camera and we shot a
ton of music videos on that and
um so that was kind of the introduction
and then our first two features we
um we had a Director of Photography who
came from photography and she was just
incredible at lighting incredible at
just answering our questions you know
and so she was picking up some of the
cinematography stuff like on the spot
too you know like as far as like you
know just eye lines and framing because
like that stuff doesn't matter when
you're just taking photos you know
because they're still
um and so just like through those
processes of like actually just being on
set and seeing that and then as you know
as I kept making things I started to AC
so that was pretty much my film school
like I am watching Everybody all the
time like why does this DP like this
lens I had a DP who always wanted to
start on a 35 millimeter just like at
the top of the day throw that on the
camera and we'll go from there you know
and it's like and just seeing like how
that affected his style you know and
like
I think you know a lot of people don't
understand like the distance you know
like when people want to give me their
storyboards I'm like I want to shoot
this on the 50 I'm like okay but you're
this far away it's going to be like
their nose you know like you know and
like but just getting that knowledge is
from being on set and seeing why people
are making the lunch choices they are
based on how far away they are and how
much they want in the shot and how much
they want and focus in that shot
um I picked all it up just from watching
so you know as a second AC as a focus
puller
um yeah it was mostly through that and
like a lot of that I started doing that
in Boston and some features but there's
not a ton of indie's work in Boston
sometimes the big Hollywood movies come
through but you're not going to get
hired on to those as like a local which
is probably correct because I don't
think any of us have like the experience
that they would expect after coming to
LA and working on film sets I'm like oh
okay I learned a ton more
um but yeah I just dove in same thing
you know the first set I got into in La
I just found it on a Facebook group they
were shooting on black magic cameras I
had one I was like I'll come out we shot
in a cabin and Big Bear and it was like
that was my first experience and then
you know I got hired by the other camera
so in that movie on to the next gig so
it just like after meeting you know five
people you start getting hired
everywhere uh and that was really just
how I I got started and you know and
I've gotten just better every movie I'm
like a little bit better
with learning cinematography what
aspects have you struggled with the most
oh man
um
I think with cinematography like it's
always like what again going back to
being a perfectionist like what would be
the perfect shot and on Indie sets I'm
always in tight spaces and I can't get
the shot that I would love to so I'm
shooting much wider than I want to the
lighting's not as good as I'd like it to
be so for me that's always a struggle
like okay I'm in like a two foot
bathroom or I'm in a hallway that's like
tiny
um so that's where I struggled like the
most as far as
what's in my head versus like what I can
actually do whereas like if you're on a
set that's built and you can move the
wall you can get whatever you want you
know
um so I think on the Indie level that's
the hardest thing is just like locations
um
hardest to learn yeah I don't know it's
all hard like the technical aspects of
it I know every time I'm gonna work with
a new camera I go read the manual the
night before
um but like all that little technical
stuff like I picked that stuff up easily
so like I'll learn the camera very
quickly I'll know all the menus I'll
know all that stuff
um and then it's really it just once you
get the basics done it's just the
aesthetic choices you know like
I want it to be very shallow Focus I
want not much in the image or the
opposite I want a lot in the image I
want a Vista I want it to be super in
focus and so it's like making those
artistic choices and then knowing how to
get those things in camera
um you know it takes like a little time
to understand the relationship between
your ISO and your aperture and your
focal distance and then how far away you
can get
um all of that like is like a little
dance that happens and that just comes
with experience to understand like I
want to do this and like without just
having to swap My Lens 40 times to see
which one is the exact thing that I want
like now I you know you start to get a
sense of what is going to work
do you usually get more than one chance
to do like a shot or two or sometimes
it's just this is the only shot we're
going to get on Indie sets yeah it moves
very very fast you know so like we're
doing 10 and up pages every day so it's
like you got 10 minutes to set this up
you know get your wide get your
close-ups and like usually I care a
little bit more than anybody else you
know so I'm like oh please can we just
do it again because the eye line is off
you know or whatever so I put my foot
down as much as I can but at the end of
the day we got to make our day and if
everybody else wants to move on we gotta
move on you know and so a lot of like
what I'm good at is just moving fast you
know with a level of quality I try to
strive for you know and like my always
my dream is to like have 20 days to
shoot something I have 30 days like I
would like be so happy
what was AV club like
um it was good you know like we would
just be a sign like all right you're
doing this basketball game follow the
ball um I would our morning
announcements were over the televisions
in every classroom so there I was like
clicking record on the kids doing like
their little news presentation for the
morning
um but yeah we would make little
commercials for little local businesses
and like I watched some of them recently
and they're terrible but they're funny
and you know and everybody seems a lot
younger than we felt at the time you
know I was like wow these babies are
like walking around without supervision
um but yeah so it's like at the time you
know we were editing VCR to vcr and like
that's like where my like film knowledge
stopped until the DSLR Revolution
basically you know I was like and you
know the student learning how to edit on
a computer but like
you know I never did any film stuff like
actual film strip I never have edited
any of it never shot it it's a dream
someday to shoot on 16 or 35. I have
plans in my brain for it but um so I
just kind of skipped from like VCR click
and go to like Premiere and dslrs
but you were used to were you the only
girl in the class
yeah
I thought you mentioned that I think I
was yeah
yeah I definitely have been used to that
all my life being the only girl around
and it's disappointing you know in music
in film everywhere like a lot of rooms
I'm in I'm often the only woman there
and uh I don't think that's good or
right
um and I hope it's changing I haven't
seen a huge shift and I know people you
know with me too and everything people
talk big like we're gonna get to parody
but I think there needs to be some sort
of money attached to it like you know
you get X tax break if you have parity
on your set you know there needs to be
like some consequence for Productions
that they're not hiring women because
the only way we're going to get women in
is if you hire them I think women have
more expenses especially as adults that
they have to worry about than a lot of
single white men that are around ready
to do the job you know like women have
kids they've got it they're the main
Caregivers for their parents you know
like there's like other expenses because
of how our society works and that the
there is no child care and there is no
Elder Care like that you have to pay
them you have to pay them to show up and
like they're ready to work it's just
like there needs to be money attached
and I think that's the biggest barrier
because nobody's gonna like go out on
their own money to be like I'm gonna
like pay extra to hire a woman you know
whatever
um there just needs to be like some
structural reason that they're forced to
do it and then it'll come naturally
right well I'm gonna play The Devil's
Advocate for a second but I I get the
sense that you're tough and you don't
need to be babied no and that's good I
think that's that and I think sometimes
that's the bad rap that women get is
that maybe just not I'm not talking
about me too but just everybody's a
little sensitive but you seem like you
can thrive in many situations and so I
think that's an advantage right well I
think especially historically you know
like if you meet women who were in the
industry
the 70s 80s 90s like they are tough as
nails like nothing you could say
anything to them they don't care you
know and they'll give it back to you
yeah no I'm here to work and I'm
professional sure you know whatever and
like I think you know you develop a
thick skin you know because I've heard
everything you know and but I'm there to
like do a good job and I'm there to like
work and I'm there to have fun as much
as I'm allowed to in like these
situations you know and like everything
else has to roll off and like but I do
keep like the mental Rolex like I'm not
gonna work with that guy again because
he said this you know and it's like so
I'm not gonna like support it but also
if you want to keep your job you know
like if you're the one complaining
you're the one that goes you know it's
never the person that said the thing or
did the thing in my experience that is
true and that's like
you're the pro the many you speak up
you're the problem and so it's just it's
unfortunate because that means nothing
changes you know it's still the boys
club